ces manifestants dénoncent la mort de
richard brooks un jeune afro américain
de 27 ans il a été abattu vendredi dans
le stationnement d'un restaurant wendy's
où il s'était endormi dans son véhicule
les deux policiers dépêchés sur les
lieux le réveil est temps de lui passer
les menottes
d'après les caméras corporelle des
policiers richard brooks résiste il se
sauve ensuite avec un pistolet à
impulsion électrique
ils pointent en direction des agents
avant d'être tué
la scène a littéralement mis le feu aux
poudres affrontements entre policiers et
manifestants restaurant incendiés la
mairesse d'atlanta a dénoncé le travail
des agents le policier qui aurait tiré
sur l'homme de 27 ans a été congédié son
collègue a été affecté à des tâches
administratives
la chef de police d'atlanta rich à chase
a démissionné dans l'état de la georgie
un pistolet à impulsion électrique n'est
pas considéré comme une arme létale
affirme l'avocat de la famille brooks
alors comment expliquer que l'agent ait
choisi de tirer une fois luis la courte
formation des policiers d'environ 20
semaines seraient tous des facteurs
expliquent ce professeur de sociologie
sur les ondes du cnn
malgré tout pour le sénateur républicain
tim scott
il est impensable de légiférer pour
encadrer usage de la force des policiers
les manifestants on ne semble pas avoir
dit leur dernier mot
ici gabriel proulx radio canada montréal